ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
MURTADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN AND PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE NUMBER [inaudible]
BY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL IN IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING.
WE WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG BY
SENATOR CAFIERO.
LET US RECALL THOSE WE'RE ALWAYS
IN GOD'S PRESENCE.
THERE'S A BLOCK I GET COLDS
SUNFLOWER SEEDS.
AND RECENTLY THE AUTHOR SISTER
MATT MELANIE'S FOR BOTHA.
SAID LITTLE SECTION ON SIX WORDS
PRAYERS.
SO I'M GONNA SHARE A FEW WITH
YOU TODAY AND MAYBE YOU CAN
THINK OF YOUR OWN DURING THE DAY.
DEAR GOD.
IT'S ME.
HELP.
A MAN.
SPEAK TO ME LORDS.
PLEASE AND THEN CA.
FUN LOVING GODS.
TICKLE MY FANCY PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR PUPPIES AND
STRAWBERRIES.
THANKS FOR ANOTHER DAY OF LIVING
[inaudible]
A MAN.
I PLEDGE. TO BUY OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC PUBLIC. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
ALL RIGHT SENATOR CAFIERO WILL
CATCH YOU AGAIN.
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
GENERAL FIFTY FIVE WILL BE
SUSPENDED FOR TODAY'S SESSION.
AND WE WILL THEN AT THIS MOMENT
MOVE TO PRIVILEGES.
OF THE FLOOR.
LET'S WAIT ONE MOMENT PLEASE
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES WE OUR A PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY --
MASAHIRO NIKISCH NISHIKAWA.
WHO IS THE MUNICIPAL OFFICER
FROM YOKOHAMA JAPAN?
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER IF WE
COULD PLEASE.
THE HAVE HIM.
STEP FORWARD SO WE CAN.
AT LEAST HE'S NOT HERE AT THE
MOMENT SO FAR THIS IS A WORKING
OUT SO WELL.
BUT IF WE COULD IN ABSENTIA WE
WILL DELIGHT TO HONOR THE FACT
THAT WE DO HAVE A CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH OUR JAPANESE.
FRIENDS AND PARTNERS AND SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO JUST RECOGNIZED
THAT HE WILL BE HERE WITH US AT
SOME POINT AND WE ALWAYS WELCOME%
OUR FRIENDS.
OF FROM THE GREAT NATION OF
JAPAN [inaudible]
MOVING ON MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND THROUGH TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED
AS CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE.
CLERK.
THIS IS FOR EXAMPLE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE NOW TO
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS [inaudible]
MISTER SECRETARY.
THE THEY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
MADAM PRO TEM UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS.
PLEASE DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE PRO TEM.
MADAM PRO TEM THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT UNDER
FILE ITEM --
ONE THIS WOULD BE THE
CONFIRMATION FOR SANDRA.
MATSUMOTO FOR THE APPOINTMENT
AND DELORES SAND OF ALL FOR THE
RE APPOINTMENT TO THE SACRAMENTO
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA CONSERVANCY.
MS MATSUMOTO IS ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR FOR THE WATER PROGRAM
AT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY MISS
SEND OF ALL IS A MATH TEACHER AT
LOS GATOS HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY EIGHTEENTH
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM IS READY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THESE
APPOINTMENTS ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
HI BELL [inaudible]
WE'RE JUST [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
BY DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
BY HUESO.
BY FOR TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY MORALE [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE.
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BY NUMBER.
AND BYE.
BYE CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
BY [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
OUR EYES THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO
THOSE APPOINT NOW TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE TIME TO
ADDRESS THE JOURNEY IN MEMORY
MOTIONS.
WE WILL START WITH SENATOR
NIELSEN.
SENATOR NIELSEN AT ALL ISN'T
THAT IS LADIES UNTIL WE GIVE
ATTENTION TO SENATOR NIELSEN WE
ARE GOING TO DO A RESOLUTION TO
A FORMER COLLEAGUE.
OF BOB PRESLEY.
EXCUSE ME TO BOB PRESSING ON
BEHALF OF HIS LATE FATHER.
THE FORMER STATE SENATOR ROBERT
CLIP PRESLEY SO IF WE COULD HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE.
CENTER NIELSEN THAT ARE PRESENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
AND PERMISSION TO DISPLAY THE
BLUE BOOK WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THIS IS A NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
ADDITION OF THE LEGISLATIVE BLUE
BOOK THERE'S A BEEN A LATER ONE
MORE RECENTLY ABOUT A DECADE AGO.
THESE USED TO BE REGULARLY
PRINTED BUT NOT SO MUCH ANYMORE
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST ONE THAT
SENATOR BOB PRESLEY APPEARED IN.
HE HAD BEEN ELECTED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF COMING ALONG FOUR
YEARS LATER AND SERVING.
MANY YEARS WITH BOB PRESLEY.
CENTER PRESLEY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WAS THE
EPITOME.
OF WHAT A CENTER [inaudible] TO
BE [inaudible]
DISTINGUISHED [inaudible]
RESPECTFUL [inaudible]
BRIGHT.
VERY FOR STUDIOUSLY.
HE DID THE RULES OF THE
INSTITUTION.
IS A FRIENDLY MAN.
HE HAD A VERY WRY SENSE OF HUMOR.
DRY AND DRY.
AND HE HAD AN INCREDIBLE
[inaudible]
LIFE.
IN WORLD WAR.
TWO HE RECEIVED THE BRONZE STAR
[inaudible]
IN COMBAT [inaudible]
IN ITALY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE HIGHEST HONORS
ACCORDED. TO A MILITARY HERO.
BUT NEVER TALKED ABOUT THAT.
AS DID MOST OF THE WORLD WAR TWO
VETERANS.
BUT HE CARRIED HIMSELF WITH THE
BEARING OF ONE WHO HAD.
BEEN IN VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS.
WHO HAD COME TO TERMS OF THOSE
SITUATIONS?
DEALT WITH THEM AND APPLIED WHAT
HE HAD LEARNED IN THOSE ARDUOUS
TIMES.
THE WHAT HE WAS DOING
[inaudible]
TODAY.
THERE WAS A AND I WAS A BRAND
NEW.
SENATOR IN THE BEEN BALD AND
CRIME VICTIMS ISSUES AND PUBLIC
SAFETY NOT TO THE DEGREE THAT
BOB PRESLEY THOUGH.
HE HAD A TWENTY FOUR YEAR CAREER.
IN THE RIVERSIDE [inaudible]
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
AFTER THAT TIME HE SERVED IN THE
THE STEAM POSITION [inaudible]
AS UNDERSHERIFF.
OF THAT COUNTY [inaudible]
HE KNEW [inaudible]
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT CAME HERE [inaudible]
ANY CERTAINLY.
DID STAKE OUT.
THE LEADERSHIP ROLE.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
BUT HE HAD MANY OTHER INTERESTS.
CHILDREN.
WERE VERY MUCH [inaudible]
OF INTEREST [inaudible]
BOB PRESLEY.
HE HAS SERVED AS HEAD OF THE
FINANCE COMMITTEE.
MANY COMMITTEES THE SERVER.
AND DURING THE PERIOD WHEN WE
WERE BUILDING PRISONS.
HE WAS A CHAIR.
APPROPRIATELY OF THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
THE CAP ON AYE ON HOW WE WERE
DOING THESE PRISONS AND THAT WE
WERE GETTING THEM DONE.
AND THAT THEY WERE FUNCTIONING.
HE WAS QUITE A ENVIRONMENTALIST
AS WELL.
KERRY MANY BILLS PARTICULAR
RELATED TO AIR QUALITY.
THE DISTRICT HE REPRESENTED IS
BEEN MUCH AFFECTED OVER THE
DECADES.
WITH AIR POLLUTION.
AND BOB IS ALWAYS.
AT THE HEAD OF THE CURVE
[inaudible]
FIGHTING. FOR CLEAN AIR. FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT HE REPRESENTED
[inaudible]
BOB PRESLEY.
VOTED.
THE DISTRICT [inaudible]
NOT [inaudible]
THE PARTY.
BUT THE DISTRICT THAT HE
REPRESENTED.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS ALWAYS SO
OVERWHELMINGLY [inaudible]
ELECTED [inaudible]
AND REELECTED.
AS A ROOKIE SENATOR I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ONE OF WHAT
WAS CALLED THE GANG OF FOUR
MAYBE IT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST SO
CALLED GAINES AROUND THIS PLACE
HAVE BEEN SEVERAL SENSE BUT THE
GANG OF FOUR THEN WAS.
BOB PRESLEY.
AND JIM NIELSEN IN THE SENATE
[inaudible]
ALISTAIR MCALLISTER.
AND DAVE STERLING IN THE
ASSEMBLY. TWO REPUBLICANS TWO
DEMOCRATS.
THE GANG OF FOUR AUTHORED ALL OF
THE MAJOR PUBLIC SAFETY BILLS.
OF THAT ERA.
AND I DO NOT KNOW WHO GAVE US
THAT DESIGNATION THE GANG OF
FOUR BUT IT WAS AN INTERESTING
COMBINATION.
A BI PARTISAN [inaudible]
AND ONE YEAR WE PUT TOGETHER
SOMETHING CALLED COMMITMENT TO
COUNTIES TO COUNTIES OF ALWAYS
BEEN THE STEPCHILD OF GOVERNMENT.
IN MANY RESPECTS.
THEN THIS WAS AN ATTEMPT TO HELP
THE COUNTIES.
VERY A SERVICE CARRIED WERE THE
LEAD WITH THE OTHERS BEING JOINT
AUTHORS.
BOB GREAT CONTRIBUTION BEING THE
LEAD AUTHOR.
OF SOMETHING THOSE CALL TRIAL
COURT FUNDING.
IN WHICH I WOULD SAY YET EVEN
TODAY IS ONE OF THE VERY FEW IF
NOT THE ONLY TIME THE STATE HAS
EVER CAPAS WORD TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
TRIAL COURT FUNDING WAS THIS
SYSTEM.
WITH THE CONDUCT THEIR TRIAL
COURTS [inaudible]
FINANCIAL.
AND IT STAYED AROUND.
IT WAS A QUESTION. FOR MANY MANY
YEARS.
AND IT CERTAINLY DID HELP OUR
COUNTIES IN UNDERSTAND THAT
KINDA CAME ON THE HEELS OF PROP.
THIRTEEN COUNTY SAN WERE
STRUGGLING.
AND THIS WAS VERY HELPFUL.
THAT I CONSIDER THAT ONE OF THE
LANDMARK ACCOMPLISHMENTS
[inaudible]
BOB PRESLEY [inaudible]
HE WITH SUCH A A FRIENDLY FELLOW.
I DON'T THINK I'VE SAW HIM GET
ANGRY.
THE MOST I COULD SAY I SAW BOB
PRESLEY AS HE WOULD GET SERIOUS.
NOW HE DID NOT END HIS
[inaudible] TEN YEAR.
SERVING THE PEOPLE.
JUST IN THE STATE SENATE.
HE THEN WENT ON TO OTHER
POSITIONS. FOR A TIME AS THE
CARE OF THE YOUTHFUL OFFENDER
PAROLE BOARD.
GOVERNOR DAVIS APPOINTED HIM.
TO THE SECRETARY.
OF THE END WAS CALLED THE YOUTH
AND ADULT CORRECTIONS AGENCY NOW
IT'S CALLED THE WHAT WOULD WE
CHANGE THE NAME HIGH GOODNESS IT
SEE -- NOT
YA QUE ANYMORE.
NOT THINK OF IT.
HE BECAME THE CHAIRMAN.
THE SECRETARY THE ENTIRE AGENCY
[inaudible]
UNDER DAVIS.
THEN WHY CAPACITY AT THE BOARD
OF PRISON TERMS.
AND BRIEFLY AT THE IS OFTEN A
PRO ABORT I GOT TO HELP AND WORK
WITH [inaudible]
BOB.
DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION IS WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR HERE.
AND BOB WAS A TOUGH ON CRIME GUY.
BUT HE ALSO [inaudible]
WAS.
VERY DEDICATED THE
REHABILITATION WITHIN THE
INSTITUTIONS.
SO THAT WHATEVER WE PUT OUT.
WHOEVER DID COME OUT UNDER ORDER
OF LAW UNDER THE TERMS SENSE LAW
OR BY APPROVAL.
ABOARD PRISON TERMS OF THE
ACTUAL OFFENDER PAROLE BOARD.
THAT THEY WERE REALLY READY.
THEY HIT THE STREETS.
BOB IS VERY DISCERNING IN THAT
REGARD.
IT DID A FINE JOB.
AND I CANNOT SAY THAT I EVER SAW
MUCH [inaudible]
PARTISANSHIP [inaudible]
BOB PRESLEY.
THEY ALWAYS RECEIVE OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT.
AND IS DISTRICT [inaudible]
FROM REPUBLICANS.
THOUGH HIS DISTRICT.
LOS LEAN REPUBLICAN AND HE WAS A
UNAPOLOGETIC DEMOCRAT.
I GATHER WHAT WE THEN CALLED A
ROOSEVELT DEMOCRAT.
LATER A REAGAN DEMOCRAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT PREOCCUPIED
BUT PRESLEY.
IT WASN'T THE POLITICAL
PERSUASION.
THAT WASN'T HOW FAR LEFT TO
RIGHT [inaudible]
ANYBODY WAS.
IT WAS WHAT WAS GOOD FOR THE
DISTRICT THAT HE REPRESENTED I
BELIEVE WAS THE THIRTY FOURTH.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MAN OF ABSOLUTE INTEGRITY.
KINDA THE CUSTODIAN OF THE
ETHICS OF THE INSTITUTION.
WAS BOB PRESLEY ANY ALWAYS
SERVED.
ON THOSE KEY COMMITTEES
[inaudible]
THE OVERSIGHT.
BOB HAD A VERY.
CLOSE KNIT STAFF [inaudible]
AND FAMILY [inaudible]
TODAY.
HIS SON BOB IS HERE WITH US.
THERE'S QUITE A RESEMBLANCE OF
HIS FATHER.
ALSO TRISH PRESLEY.
THAT'S BOB'S WIFE.
MARYLAND RAFAEL.
AND DONNA DANIELS THOSE ARE
BOB'S SISTER'S.
ADD UP HIS STAFF THAT I'VE
GOTTEN TO KNOW WELL OVER THE
YEARS. TO SUSAN WALLACE.
BOB FRENZY IS BACK IN THE ROOM
HERE AND THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
THEM COME UP SO WE CAN RECOGNIZE
IN WITH --
CENTER ROTH.
RICHARD MARX IN [inaudible]
SUSAN WALLACE.
AND KAREN FRENCH.
KAREN HAS BEEN A LONG TIME
INSTITUTION HERE WORKED BOB ON
THE FISCAL COMMITTEE.
AND SHE TOLD ME TODAY THAT SHE
JUST RETIRED.
MAYBE A APPROPRIATE TIME FOR HIM
TO RETIRE WHEN WE'RE RECOGNIZING
THEIR FORMER BOSS [inaudible]
BOB PRESLEY.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE SERVE HERE A
LITTLE OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED IN
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
SERVED IN THE STATE SENATE OF
ALL THE BILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LIVED IN THE STATE
[inaudible]
BOB PRESLEY.
WILL RATE IS ONE OF THE BEST.
EVEN AT THE TIME VARIOUS.
INSTITUTIONS THAT RATED
LEGISLATORS.
ALWAYS PUT BOB.
THE TO TALK.
HE MANAGES BILLOWED ABLY.
DIDN'T KERRY STATEMENT BILLS.
THE BILL SHE CARRIED
[inaudible]
WE'RE IMPORTANT.
THEY GOT MOST OF THEM PASSED.
THEY GOT ALONG VERY WELL WITH
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS.
AS WELL AS DEMOCRATIC.
GOVERNORS.
IN THE AS I NOTED HE WAS EVEN
APPOINTED AGENCY SECRETARY.
THAT IS THE RESUL CORRECTIONS.
BY GOVERNOR DAVIS.
IF YOU EVER WANTED.
TO CRAFT WHAT I WOULD SAY THE
PERFECT.
PERSON. TO BE HONEST HONORABLE
BODY.
MEMBER OF IT.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN [inaudible]
AND WAS.
SENATOR BOB PRESS.
I ASKED LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THAT YOU.
HONOR HIM TODAY.
THE JOURNEY IN HIS MEMORY.
BUT DON'T LET THAT JUST PASSED
TODAY.
THOSE OF YOU WHO NOW SERVE.
KEEP IN MIND DOES TO PASS
THROUGH HERE BEFORE YOU.
AND WHEN WE MEMORIALIZE SOMEONE
LIKE BOB PRESLEY.
KEEPING ON YOUR MIND
[inaudible]
WHY?
BECAUSE THERE WERE GOOD EXAMPLES
OF INDIVIDUALS WHOSE EXAMPLE
OUGHT NOT BE LOST.
ON US TODAY.
WHEN THINGS ALONG WITH DIFFERENT?
A BIT MORE PARTISAN RULES ARE
NOT AS IMPORTANT.
LET'S THINK ABOUT THE TIME WHEN
THERE WERE PEOPLE THE WORK
HISTORIANS OF THAT INTEGRITY.
AND THAT RESPECT FOR THE
INSTITUTION [inaudible]
BOB PRESLEY.
IS THAT PERSON.
MAY GOD BLESS HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
MAYBE REST IN THE MANSIONS OF
THE LORD.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
IN MEMORY OF BOB PRESLEY.
I THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN ON
THIS IN TURN IN MEMORY.
SENATOR STONE ARE YOU.
PREPARED TO SPEAK ON THIS
JOURNEY MEMORY.
YES MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR SEE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND AND
COLLEAGUES AT WITH GREAT SADNESS
THAT I I STAND AND JOIN IN THE
ADJOURNMENT OF THE MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND BOB PRESLEY WHO.
I HAD THE HONOR OF OF KNOWING
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN FACT HE
WAS MY SENATOR.
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHEN.
WE ONLY HAD ABOUT FIVE OR SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVING
THERE IN OUR COUNTY WHICH IS NOW
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF MILLION HE
PROBABLY REPRESENTED JUST ABOUT
MOST OF THE GEOGRAPHICAL MASSIVE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY IS.
IS I DO TODAY [inaudible]
AND OUR FRIENDSHIP CONTINUED AS
HE WAS UNDER SHARE FOR THE
COUNTY AND THEN BECAME A THE
pCONSULTING HIM WHEN I DECIDED I
WAS GONNA --
CONSIDER RUNNING FOR THE STATE
SENATE AND HE WAS --
NOT ONLY ENCOURAGING ME TO DO SO
AFTER SEEING MY DEDICATION HIS
THAT MY DEDICATION TO RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BUT EVEN ENDORSED ME AS A
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR WHICH I FELT
VERY VERY HONORED.
I MADE A POINT EVERY YEAR WHEN I
CAME TO SACRAMENTO TO TAKE HIM
OUT FOR DINNER AND TO CATCH UP
WITH HIM AND WE MET AT
PARTICULAR RESTAURANT AND HE WAS
ALWAYS THERE BEFORE I WAS HE WAS
VERY PUNCTUAL AND SHOWING UP IN.
I WOULD SHOW UP IN THE GREETER
WAS SAY HOW CAN I HELP YOU I
SAID AS I AM HERE TO BE WITH
SENATOR PRESLEY AND JUST COME
RIGHT THIS WAY AND I WOULD WALK
UP AND SAY CENTER PRESLEY IT'S
GREAT TO SEE YOU IN HIS EYES
WOULD JUST LIGHT.
UP I MEAN YOU COULD TELL THIS
MAN -- LOVES
BEING A SENATOR LOVE BEING A
PUBLIC SERVANT.
AND WE TALK ABOUT HIS TIME IN
THE SENATE.
WE TALKED ABOUT [inaudible]
HIS FRIENDSHIP.
WITH THOSE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE.
MOST NOTABLY SENATOR DAVE KELLY
HOW MANY OF YOU PROBABLY
REMEMBER WHILE THEY WERE BOTH
SENATORS FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
FROM DIFFERENT PARTIES AND HE
OFTEN REMINISCE HOW THEY WOULD --
GO ACROSS THE STREET AT THE
HYATT AND HAVE A COUPLE OF
DRINKS AND SETTLE THE SCORE.
AND MOVE LEGISLATION.
I IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
CALIFORNIA.
BOTH COMPROMISING TO TO DO WHAT
WAS BEST. FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW THERE'S ONE COMMON
DENOMINATOR OF BEING A MEMBER OF
A FAMILY.
AND BEING A MEMBER OF THE SENATE.
AND IS THAT ISSUED CANNOT PICK
YOUR RELATIVES.
AND YOU CAN OPERATE PICKLE YOUR
YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE IN THE
SENATE.
BUT AS FAMILY MEMBERS.
AS MEMBERS OF THE SENATE.
WE LEARN TO GET ALONG WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
AND WE LEARNED TO WORK WITH ONE
AND BOB SET THE SHINING EXAMPLE.
I'M BI PARTISANSHIP [inaudible]
FRIENDSHIP.
AND ALSO MAINTAINING.
THE HIGH STANDARDS.
THAT WE HAVE IN THE INSTITUTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WE HAVE A DETENTION CENTER IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY RIVERSIDE IS
NAMED AFTER HIM BECAUSE OF HIS.
PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTY.
HE IS REVERED ANNE'S LOVED AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND AGAIN I HOPE HE SETS THE
EXAMPLE. FOR ALL OF US THAT CAN
PROBABLY ALL IMPROVE AND DO
BETTER.
IN HAVING RESPECT FOR ONE
ANOTHER RESPECTING EACH OTHER'S
PHILOSOPHIES AND OPINIONS AND
ISSUES THAT.
MANY TIMES ARE PURPOSELY TRYING
TO DIVIDE US.
WE HAVE SO MUCH MORE IN COMMON
AND THAT'S WHAT BOB PRESLEY
TAUGHT US IS WE HAVE SO MUCH IN
COMMON WITH SOME BRIEFS THAT
[inaudible]
COMMON GROUND.
AND LET'S DO THE BEST THAT WE
CAN NOT ONLY FOR DISTRICTS AS
BOB WAS A CHAMPION FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
BUT THAT'S DO WHAT'S IN THE BEST
THE BEST INTERESTS OF MAKING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS GOLDEN AS CAN BE.
MY FRIENDS I CAN TELL YOU.
I GOT A BIRTHDAY COMING UP
YOU'RE GONNA BE SIXTY THREE
YEARS OLD IT SEEMS LIKE
YESTERDAY I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
LIFE GOES VERY VERY FAST.
BUT A GOOD NAME LAST FOREVER.
AND ROBERT PRESSLEY SENATOR
ROBERT PRESSLEY.
HIS NAME A RAIN IN THIS CAPITOL
FOR MANY MANY DECADES TO COME.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FOR
LINE MEDIA.
INJURED IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE
[inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
PEOPLE WISH TO SPEAK.
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW BOB PRESLEY'S LIFE WAS
ABOUT SERVICE.
SERVICE TO HIS FAMILY SERVICE TO
HIS COMMUNITY.
AND SERVICE TO HIS COUNTRY.
MY COLLEAGUE A SPOKE ELOQUENTLY
ABOUT SENATOR PRESLEY'S SERVICE
IN WORLD WAR TWO MEMBER OF THE
GREATEST GENERATION.
WE FEE SERVE A GENERAL MARK MARK
AND THAT FIFTH ARMY IN ITALY.
WE'RE HE RECEIVED A BRONZE STAR
FOR HER WAS AMEND.
FRANKLY THAT WAS SOME OF THE
TOUGHEST FIGHTING THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE HISTORIANS KNOW SOME OF
THE TOUGHEST FIGHTING.
IN WORLD WAR.
TWO IN ITALY.
WITH THAT ARMY.
BUT YOU WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN IT
BY TALKING TO SENATOR BOB
PRESLEY.
I NEVER DID IN ALL THE YEARS.
THAT I KNEW IN.
HE WAS A MAN OF DISTINCT GRAYSON
HUMILITY A MAN OF COURAGE.
AND A MAN OF DECENCY.
YOU KNOW DURING HIS TIME IN THE
SENATE HE WORKED ACTUALLY WORKED
ACROSS THE AISLE. TO GET STUFF
DONE SORT OF A NOVEL CONCEPT
THESE DAYS.
OUR YOU MAY NOT KNOW THIS BUT IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO HE WAS ON
THE TICKET AS BOTH THE
DEMOCRATIC AND THE REPUBLICAN.
NOMINEE AND CANDIDATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
AND AFTER SEARCHING OUR STATE
ARCHIVES OUR CURRENT SECRETARY
OF STATE [inaudible]
HAS CONFIRMED.
BUT HE'S THE ONLY POLITICIAN.
IN MODERN HISTORY TO HAVE DONE
SO.
NEEDLESS TO SAY SENATOR BOB
PRESLEY WON THAT RACE.
IN ADDITION TO HIS WORK IN
PUBLIC SAFETY WHICH MY COLLEAGUE
IS HIGHLY HIGHLIGHTED.
IN SOME DETAIL.
YOU SHOULD ALSO KNOW THAT BOB
PRESLEY FOUGHT. FOR SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND ABUSE
ESTABLISHING SHELTERS AND
RESOURCES.
AROUND THE STATE TO HELP WOMEN
AND CHILDREN IMPACTED.
BY THOSE HEINOUS CRIMES.
AND TOGETHER WITH FORMER
ASSEMBLYMAN THEN LATER
CONGRESSMAN JERRY LEWIS.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE MODERN DAY
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
LEADING [inaudible]
TO CLEAN AIR.
IN INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THE CLEANER.
THAT WE MOSTLY ENJOY.
TODAY HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE AND HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO
OUR NATION WILL BE FELT FOR
GENERATIONS. FOR MAKING OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS SAFER TO THE AIR
WE BREATHE CLEANER. TO OUR
POLITICS MORE COMPASSIONATE
[inaudible]
AND DIGNIFIED.
IN MY VIEW.
HE WAS ONE OF THE FINEST PUBLIC
SERVANTS CALIFORNIA WILL
PROBABLY.
EVER SEE.
NOW I FIRST MET.
BOB PRESLEY IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE FORTY YEARS AGO.
I WAS A YOUNG AIR FORCE CAPTAIN
IN THOSE DAYS WORKING FOR A
LIEUTENANT COLONEL BOB BOSS AT
MARCH AIR FORCE BASE.
AND ' AYE
CENTER PRESS THE WITH THE BILL.
TO ASSIST MILITARY MEMBERS WHO
WERE SUMMONED TO JURY SERVICE.
AND I ACTUALLY --
DRAFTED PART OF THAT BILL.
SO WHEN IT CAME TIME FOR THE
BILL TO MOVE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
BOB PRESLEY INVITED OBVIOUSLY MY
BOSS BUT ALSO INVITED ME TO COME
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
TO TESTIFY IS THAT YOUNG
[inaudible]
CAPTAIN.
YOU KNOW I BEGGED OFF.
FRANKLY THE THOUGHT OF COMING TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
INTIMIDATED ME.
FUNNY HOW THINGS WORK OUT.
OVER THE YEARS HE BECAME A
MENTOR TO ME WE SERVED ON
COMMUNITY BOARDS AND ADVOCACY
GROUPS TOGETHER.
AND HE WAS ONE OF FRANKLY TWO OR
THREE PEOPLE WHO CONVINCED ME TO
RUN FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE OF FOLLOWING
REDISTRICTING.
AND HE CONTINUED TO CHEER AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WOULD DO I MET HIM.
FOR LUNCH ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
AFTER COMING UP HERE AND HE
CONTINUED TO CHEER ME ON AFTER
THAT TO ENCOURAGE ME TO TALK
ABOUT WORKING ACROSS THE AISLE
EVEN IN THIS POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT.
AND HOW BENEFICIAL IT WAS BOTH
TO HIS CAREER AND TO THE
RESIDENTS OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN
THE RESIDENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY
SENATOR BOB PRESLEY GAVE MY WIFE
CINDY HER FIRST JOB.
AT AGE SEVENTEEN IN HIS
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE DISTRICT
OFFICE IN RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA
AND CONTINUED TO MENTOR HER AND
GUIDE HER IN HER CAREER FOR AS
LONG AS HE LIVED.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS I'VE SAID
THIS BEFORE.
BOB PRESLEY WAS A TRUE GENTLEMAN
IN A WORLD THAT UNFORTUNATELY
APPEARS TO HAVE NO FURTHER USE
[inaudible] FOR GENTLEMAN.
HE WILL BE MISSED.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH.
SENATOR NIELSEN IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU WISH TO
PRESENT OF ITEMS RESOLUTIONS TO
THE FAMILY SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PERHAPS.
A CLOSE AND DO SO --
AT THE APPROACH HIM STATUS SHE'S
A IF THE FAMILY WOULD PLEASE
JOIN US HERE IN THE MID BAY HERE.
I SPEAK FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
THESE ARE MARIAM'S THAT THE
SENATE.
DOES PRESENT TO THE FAMILIES.
THESE OUR MEMORIAM SIT THE
SENATE PRESENTS TO FAMILIES.
OF THOSE WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
FOR OR THAT WE HAVE LOST BUT WE
WANT TO RECOGNIZE.
IT'S A VERY NICE.
THE MORE I AM AND I CAN THINK OF
NO ONE MORE DESERVING.
THAN BOB PRESLEY AND YOU HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND FORMER
EMPLOYEES BY MAY GIVE THESE TO
YOU BOB.
I THANK YOU COLLEAGUES IF WE
COULD GIVE A VERY WARM.
THANKS AND APPRECIATION TO A
GREAT MAN
.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN AND
THANK YOU TO THE PRESLEY FAMILY
FOR JOINING US.
AND FOR THE GREAT LEGACY THAT
THE GREAT.
LATE SENATOR LEFT FOR ALL OF US
TO TRY TO EMULATE [inaudible]
AND WITHOUT.
WE WILL CONTINUE WITH OUR
JOURNEY IN MEMORIES.
OF I BELIEVE.
THE SENATOR STONE HAS ONE
PERHAPS WE CAN WAIT WHILE THE
PICTURES TAKEN AND THEN WE'LL.
MOVE FORWARD [inaudible]
UP.
CENTER STONE WOULD YOU LIKE. TO
TWO AND A TURN IN MEMORY.
I BELIEVE FOR THE LATE GREAT
CAROL CHANNING.
SENATOR STONE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
FIGURE GET MAD ABOUT PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO DURING
THE SENATE IN THE MEMORY OF A
BELOVED LEGENDARY SHOW BUSINESS
I MISS CAROL CHANNING A LONG
TIME RESIDENT OF RANCHO MIRAGE
WHO PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
FIFTEENTH THAT THE NICE OLD AGE
OF NINETY SEVEN KNOWN FOR HER
STARRING ROLES ON BROADWAY
MUSICALS.
HELLO DOLLY IN GENTLEMEN PREFER
BONDS.
HER CAREER SPANNED SEVEN DECADES
WHERE SHE WON MULTIPLE TONY
AWARDS AND EMMY AND WAS
NOMINATED FOR THE PRESTIGIOUS
ACADEMY AWARD.
SHE PERFORMED HER SIGNATURE ROLE
OF DOLLY LEVY ON BROADWAY IN ON
STAGES AROUND THE WORLD.
OVER THREE THOUSAND TIMES.
CAROL CHANNING WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE IN SEATTLE
AND GOT HER FIRST TASTE OF SHOW
BUSINESS AS A YOUNG GIRL.
OVER THE DECADES SHE MADE
NUMEROUS TELEVISION APPEARANCES
IN FILMS.
CAROL CHANNING MADE HER
PERMANENT HOME IN RANCHO MIRAGE
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT SHE WAS
VERY ACTIVE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
PERFORMED IN MANY CHARITY EVENTS
AND BENEFIT CONCERTS.
SHE WAS VERY ACTIVE WITH THE
AIDS IS THE ARTS INSTITUTE OF
PALM SPRINGS HIGH SCHOOL THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF THE
COACHELLA VALLEY.
THE DESERT AIDS PROJECT JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICE OF THE DESERT IN
THE PALM SPRINGS AIR MUSEUM TO
MENTION A FEW.
CAROL CHANNING WAS AN
ENTERTAINER.
AND A SERVANT TO HER COMMUNITY.
SHE WILL BE MISSED BY ALL OF
THOSE WHO LOVED HER AROUND THE
WORLD AND LOCALLY.
AND REMEMBERED BY ALL OF THOSE
AND SHE HELPED THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ALLOWING ME TO MATT TO
MEMORIALIZE HER TODAY AS THANK
YOU SENATOR STONE AND FOR THOSE
OF US WHO REMEMBER HER.
WE CAN SAY HELLO AND GOODBYE
DOLLY THERE WAS ONLY.
ONE OTHER A JOURNEY IN MEMORY I
BELIEVE SENATOR MORALE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
IN MEMBERS I RISE --
TWO DURING IN THE MEMORY OF
CLYDE FRANCISCO --
FROM MY AREA A LONG TIME FRIEND
OF A CHAFEE UNIFIED BOB HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT HE WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN IN
HASTINGS NEBRASKA.
AND MOVED TO CALIFORNIA AT TWO
YEARS OLD.
IN NINETEEN FORTY ONE IS WHEN HE
ENROLLED AT JP HIGH SCHOOL AFTER
GRADUATING HE ENLISTED IN THE U.
S. NAVY WORRY PROUDLY SERVED
URINE --
SERVE THIS COUNTRY DURING WORLD
WAR -- TWO
CLYDE MEADOWS WIFE OF SIXTY
SEVEN YEARS BARBARA AT CHAFEE
KALI SO YOU CAN KIND OF SEE.
HIS AFFINITY FOR CHAFEE.
HIS CAREER WITH SHAPE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SPAN ACTUALLY OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
HE WAS A COACH HE WAS A TEACHER
HE ALSO NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
WAS ELECTED AS A MEMBER TO THE
SCHOOL BOARD AND FINALLY RETIRED.
IN -- TWO
THOUSAND TEN CLYDE ALSO
SUPPORTED --
THE JV SCHOOL DISTRICT ALL
DURING AS AN ADULT LIFE AND HE
WAS KNOWN AS MR CHAFEE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES A NAME THE GM
AT JP HIGH SCHOOL AFTER HIM
OTHER CLYDE SEE FRANCISCO
GYMNASIUM.
IN -- MISTER
FRANCIS CELS HONOR SO CLEITUS
ARRIVE BY IS LOVELY WIFE BARBARA --
AND THEIR THREE GROWN CHILDREN
AND FOUR GRANDCHILDREN AND THREE
GREAT.
GRANDCHILDREN --
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR TAKING
TIME TO LISTEN TO THE SOJOURNER
MEMORY TODAY ON BEHALF OF MR
CHAFEE --
STIR CLYDE FRANCISCO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER MARYLAND OF
PLEASE --
MAKE SURE TO BRING THE NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED MISTER FRANCISCO'S.
OF LIFE.
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES WHO GOING
TO PRESIDENT MEMBERS THAT FOR
PURPOSES OF INTERACTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
WHAT TODAY IN THE GALLERY I'M
VERY DELIGHTED THAT WE HAVE THE
FOURTH GRADE CLASS?
FROM -
BIRCH LANE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
DAVIS CALIFORNIA WITH THEIR
TEACHER MRS LOG --
MEMBERS THIS IS THE FUTURE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LIKE TO
GIVE THEM A WARM SENATE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU SIR DOT AND WELCOME.
TO THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIA LEADERS.
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I WOULD
LIKE TO WONDER PRIVILEGES OF OF
THE FLOOR ASK YOU.
TO DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
REAR OF THE HALL WHERE MISTER
MISH MOSH HE HE H. MASAHIRO.
NISHIKAWA THE MUNICIPAL OFFICER
FROM YOKOHAMA JAPAN IS WITH US
AT THIS POINT IN TIME IT IS
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO PRIVILEGED
TO HAVE OUR FRIENDS.
AND COLLEAGUES FROM THE GREAT
NATION OF JAPAN WITH US AND IF
WE COULD ALL GIVE HIM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO WELCOME INTO OUR
CHAMBER
.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I KNOW WE'VE
HAD A PRODUCTIVE WEEK I HOPE
EVERYONE HAS A WONDERFUL WEEKEND
AT HOME WE WILL RECONVENE.
ON MONDAY JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
AT TWO PM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT
TWO PM